uh so I saw this clip on Twitter and
I've seen it a few times in this one
show and I've been meaning to watch it
because I was just like [__] it I really
want to see the context behind this
goddamn clip
um so I watched a show called uh Golden
Boy oh yeah
right dub right I watched the dub
because of course you have to because I
I I heard the dub and I was like that
sounds really dumb and really funny I
want to watch it yeah and it's the pool
scene I saw actually I've seen the ball
scene before and I've seen the bike
scene yeah oh yeah and you've probably
seen these floating around the internet
if you've been around long enough
there's a scene that's quite popular
that I feel like it does the rounds
every every few months where a guy is
like dead serious and then it looks like
a serious swimming competition does
happen that he jumps in and goes
10 seconds and then there's another
scene that always pops up you might have
seen where a dude is like cycling on
electrical wires yeah and then jumps off
a [__] it's like the most insane [__]
and I watched it and I was like God this
is such a good show unironically oh no
no it is good and so horny
I think I think part of the reason it's
so good is the Dub's [__] amazing I
think it's so funnily bad yeah the main
guy is screaming gaming constant yeah
it's I I think the main I'm not sure if
this is true but I think I heard the
main that's this is like the main guy's
only voice acting role and I believe it
because it's it seems like it doesn't
sound like you he's come from a
traditional voice acting background
literally
I feel like it's just because animes are
expressive I think they took that as
like oh my God it's like literally
anything happens and he just starts
screaming and it's so funny yeah it's so
good it's so chaotic but the voice
setting is just good enough to make it
funny when it's bad yeah because because
he's like John explained the plot as
well I can't remember the plot yeah I
guess I just watched it yeah essential
essentially it's about this guy who's
traveling across Japan and he's quite
intelligent but also really dumb at the
same time and very perverted obviously
yeah and every single episode kind of
centers around uh a very attractive
woman so he starts and there's always an
attractive woman and they straight up
just showed titty a lot in this thing
yeah man it was a different time it's
it's it's there's the scene with a girl
and a motorcycle and uh this girl just
nuts to on a motorcycle yeah just in the
front of this guy at a gas station she's
like a very attractive I would Describe
MILF
um and she just nuts from the vibration
of the engine yeah and then it proceeds
to get like there's proceeds to be a
downhill race where he beats a
motorcycle and he's and he just jumps
off cliffs it's the most insane [__]
it's so funny it's so good and the whole
show is uh how he goes to these new jobs
and these people don't like him but then
he proves to be really good and
resourceful even though he's a massive
pervert and it's just fun it's like 30
minute episodes that all unfortunately
only six episodes six episodes but also
they were all they used six 10 out of 10
episodes oh dude I was laughing crying
at so many points it's so funny it's so
good the animation is actually amazing
oh yeah it looks insane it's still looks
amazing there's so many scenes in there
just I I remember so many [__] scenes
in there just some I think of the voice
acting plays a massive part as well
because you never know what to expect oh
yeah right we're no no we we've had
enough expectations so many times yeah
we've heard enough like anime voice
sites would be to be like okay in a
comedy anime this is where the punch
line is or this is what it's going to
sound like in XXX
um and in Golden Boy there would just be
like this random line that he speaks in
the most like out of context it feels
like half the lines definitely were just
added in and definitely weren't there in
the original yeah yeah so weird and so
fun
um but the characters really likable
even though he does like a bunch of
weird stuff that normally you'd be like
every episode he uh all the women he at
some point for some reason is cleaning
their toilets and every single episode
he starts like kissing the toilets and
then of course the woman always walks in
yeah and it's just always it's always
just weird how it all kind of plays in
it's all very like perfect it's like if
Mr Bean was a massive pervert Yeah
if you're gonna make a character like
degenerate go 100 oh yeah because if you
make them just a little bit degenerate
you like because they're so degenerate
where you suspend disbelief are you
suspend us believe to be like they
they're saying a real person if you just
add like a little bit of it then
sometimes just like man what why you got
to be so why you gotta be like that it
becomes awkward [__] melioda smell
like [__] it up like you yours you are
so [__] close you know and then you
just had this one little thing and
you're like why did that need to be
there yeah so if you're gonna make
someone degenerate just like go 100 like
110 yeah
um and that's what they did with Golden
Boy so good it's so [__] horny but
it's horny to the point where you just
don't take it seriously and it just adds
to that humor
it's such a good show it is it's very
good so worth the watch it is
humor to like the like to done to like
the finest degree it's like humor and
then they just show you literally like
the sexiest
and it's so well done it's insane it got
me thinking I was like damn and every
woman in it is like a MILF and I was
like damn where did we go wrong with
anime like in the 90s they were just it
was all about MILFs like back in the
good old days I genuinely I've never
said it before I was born in the wrong
generation
they had it they had it right back then
and now it's all [__] you gotta watch
more 90 shows everyone's like a 12 year
old 200 vampire you know it's like what
is this [__] where are the 90s officers
the 90s of year era man they had
something
Wild Things guys women who are hot and
work in offices uh who uh Stern and want
to beat you up and I'm like that's what
we need back I don't want these Lolly
vampire women I don't want them get rid
of them I want them I want these office
workers back
honestly like it's because here's here's
the thing about something like Golden
Boy I find it so rare to find a comedy
anime that actually makes me like laugh
oh yeah it's so good it's I can count on
like one hand the amount of comedy anime
I think are actually like gut bustingly
like funny yeah and gordonboy is one of
those shows definitely because I feel
like anime anime comedy a lot of the
times I find like really like slapstick
but it's I I rarely find it like haha
funny it's just like oh you know I think
it's I think the one for me obviously
comedy is subjective but I think the
ones for me are just like the more
absurdist comedy yeah like the ones
where it's just like like Golden Boy
right where it's like you can't you
don't know what's happening next yeah
and it's that like subversion of
expectation to like the most ridiculous
conclusion that makes it really like
that's why like you know like I find
shows like nichijo and ginto are really
funny because it's like it does that
exact same thing of like you think the
joke's going one way and it's like nope
we're just gonna go complete 180 and
just show you the most ridiculous [__]
right yeah and I feel a lot of like
comedy anime especially nowadays really
struggled to do that because I don't
know the babies because like they're
afraid of like alienating Their audience
I don't know I think they've always
struggled to do that comedy anime are
like really [__] hard to find a lot
of times because a lot of times the joke
is oh trip on your panties oh look at me
oh I walk into you when you're showering
oh no please oh don't hit me no and I'm
just like oh okay okay all right uh like
like I said if you're gonna go that
direction like one comedy anime or one
comedy manga that has made me laugh out
loud is like prison school back in the
day where yeah it's just a bunch it's
the most DJing [__] holy [__] it is the
definition of boys will be boys but but
like like Grand blue as well as another
reason oh yeah ground blue
it was the most likely
yeah it is the most yeah that is the
most like lad energy yeah it's one of
the few manga I've ever read uh that
reminds me of an old school you know
college comedy film remember those back
in the day when we had like [__]
Americans like the American Pie man yeah
super bad and that kind of thing but
it's like seeing that kind of humor
translated in a Japanese lens I thought
it was like really [__] interesting
and it's one of the funniest things that
one of the funniest manga I think I've
read yeah uh definitely both prison
school and ground blue uh just like it's
really really hard to make me laugh out
loud yeah so those definitely did that
for sure